series president says any US military
strike against his regime would be based
on lies Seth Doane is in the capital of
Damascus he is the only American network
correspondent inside the country Seth
good morning good morning as the US and
its allies contemplate ways to punish
Syrian President Bashar al-assad and
forces loyal to him here in government
controlled Damascus the focus has been
on advances they've made on the
battlefield Syria's government is
gaining ground and formerly rebel-held
Eastern Goethe so much so that Russia
Syria's strongest ally declared victory
in the biggest town their Duma though
notably the Syrian army has not and says
the battle for the Damascus suburb may
not be over rebels and residents are
being bused from the area in an
evacuation deal with the government
Friday is a day off here and it was
quiet this morning
in central Damascus are you afraid we've
been holding on Omar dahi be explained
and at war for seven years
Syrian President Bashar al-assad has
appeared confident and unfazed Thursday
he met with representatives from Iran
another ally and said that the u.s.
posture is a reaction to progress on the
battlefield at a cafe down the street we
asked about Saturday's alleged chemical
attack the response was unanimous these
men asked why would Assad used chemical
weapons if Syria is winning the war it's
all lies Abdul Ali told us remember this
is government-held territory where
support for Assad runs deep and also as
this war grinds into its eighth year
we've heard from people that they are
weary and do not want to see it escalate
or enter a new phase John sat down for
us on the streets of Damascus thanks
Seth